the hello welcome to this video is a bit
unusual video has a setting already it's
a little bit a little bit unusual yeah
what is all about I've use a map here of
the western United States to to
illustrate this video this is not about
me or chess directly it's about a friend
of mine who is currently traveling this
this area of the world you see this
little um marquee that's Durango in
Colorado and this is where he messaged
me from yesterday so he's currently
traveling um these states eh well i will
go to i don't know what said what's next
I think Arizona should be next and
ultimately he will be in California his
name is Mikael German pronunciation or
mike leigh's in his mid-30s also chess
play and also chess coach not a
professional one but his son done lots
of teaching with with kids mostly um
yeah so what you asked me to do is to
tell people that is currently traveling
especially in California is going to be
just a couple of days until it will be
in california and here i wanted me to
ask my channel if there are any
Californian residents may be in Los
Angeles or San Francisco whatever it is
who would be interested in meeting with
them maybe introduce some tour to a
local chess club or go to a tournament
or something like that so one if you are
in this area here like California
probably we have some years there you
can send them a message and maybe meet
up he does have some kind of travel
route but it's not very well defined so
you can easily switch to on ya alter the
route that you can visit your place or
something like that so yeah if you're
interested make sure to message him I'll
attach the email on to this to this
video and also link to his YouTube
channel currently has a not very active
youtube channel with what something that
he wants to change but anyway so yeah
make sure to mail them
if you want to get into contact and yeah
medium in the next couple of days maybe
next week I think he still will be
traveling roughly two to two to three
weeks um if i'm not mistaken ok guys
thanks for watching bye bye